Speaker 1: The NAACP has issued issued
a travel advisory in response to Ron
Desantis's attempts to ban books about race
and LGBTQ identity, reject a new AP class on
African-American studies, ban diversity, equity
and inclusion programs in Florida colleges.
Quote Florida is openly hostile to
African-Americans, people of color, LGBTQ
plus individuals. Before traveling to Florida,
please understand that the state of Florida
devalues and marginalizes the contributions of
and the challenges faced by African-Americans
and other communities of color. And it also
says if you decide to travel to Florida,
be advised, Florida public schools won't teach
your children accurate African-American history.
The state of Florida does not value diversity,
equity and inclusion. The state of Florida
doesn't welcome the contributions of
African-Americans as people of color,
etc., etc., etc.. So a few different things to
this. On the one hand, sort of proving the point.
I saw wildly racist responses to this online,
including people saying, Hey, Florida's only
dangerous because of the black people. Maybe
this will keep black people out of the state.
The right wing subreddit conservative was openly
celebrating. Hey, you know what? We should welcome
this. This might make it so fewer black people
travel to Florida. Although the Post said less
black people rather than fewer. But I'm giving
it to you in a grammatically correct way. So a
couple of different aspects to this. First of all,
the very reaction to this advisory by the NAACP
proves much of what the NAACP is saying, period,
End of story. Secondly, the fact that in the U.S.
there are travel warnings to different states
based on this sort of thing, points to the
retrograde and backwards nature of what's going
on in the United States. But lastly, as a little
travel advisory, I don't know, like, for example,
the first thing on the list is be aware that if
you travel to Florida, your kids aren't going
to be taught X, Y, Z. Most people traveling to
Florida are going on vacation. They're not putting
their kids in school. So I hesitate to take this
completely seriously as a literal travel advisory.
But I think the point here is to be more than a
literal travel advisory. The idea here is bring
attention to what's going on in Florida. Point to
how these policies in Florida disproportionately
impact marginalized communities of all kind.
Black folks, folks, LGBT folks, women. When it
comes to the abortion ban that has been passed
and their families, of course. So I see this
advisory not, as you know, the advisory that the
U.S. State Department has about traveling to the
Sinaloa region of Mexico, where they say, listen,
significant cartel activity, if you get into
trouble there, you may be beyond help from the
U.S. embassy. This is not that. This is not that.
But it is a form of activism that raises awareness
and it encourages dialog and the need for rights
and protections and points to many of the things
that are going on, going on and going wrong in the
state of Florida. Now, there are people who saw
this advisory and said, this is very unfair.
This is very unfair to Florida as a whole,
because you have so many parts of Florida where
even if it is the case that on paper teachers are
not allowed to do X, Y, Z, it is actually in the
liberal parts of Florida. It is welcomed. Nobody
is blowing the whistle. You look at places like
Miami and Miami Beach and other liberal areas. The
LGBT community is welcome. There are absolutely no
risk danger whatsoever. Black folks are welcomed.
And I have to tell you, having spent time in those
areas, I believe that that's true. But still,
it's really important to understand the underlying
message here. Even if state decrees from DeSantis
are being ignored in the liberal parts of
Florida, which to a great degree they are.
It is still the case that as a state, Florida
is not fostering inclusivity, it's not promoting
equality, it's not combating discrimination.
In fact, it seems to be building it. So I think
let's not dismiss this outright because it's not
a literal travel advisory per the interpretation
of some. Let's use it to remind ourselves
of the right wing hellscape that DeSantis
is trying to turn Florida into. He hasn't yet
succeeded, certainly not in all parts of Florida,
but that's not a reason to ignore this. So a very
interesting declaration from the NAACP. We're
going to take a quick break. We have a packed
program today. I do want to remind you that we
are just one week away from Monday, Memorial Day
on Monday, Memorial Day this year. That will be
the 29th. Do I even know what year it is? Yes, May
29th. We are doing a one day membership special,
doing what we can to jump start support for this
program as we build into the 2024 election. If
you've been saying maybe I'll get one of those
memberships. I don't know, David. I kind of like
the show, but I don't like you enough to pay
full price. Fair. Fair. Monday morning will be
sending out an email to everyone on our mailing
list with an incredible coupon code. I would
love for you to get on that newsletter at David
Packman dot com. You'll be notified first thing
Monday morning and then we will welcome you
with open arms into the ranks of membership.